hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on fawn again today
like I said it's step stream recap day
you know it's the new release of the
year you're for season one hope is now
live today but you're gonna be getting
into a lot of that info of course if you
haven't seen any of the stuff and you
have no clue what's going on with this
new year new season go check my past
videos that are still on my channel
that'll keep you all up to speed on
what's going on you definitely don't
want to miss those but by the time you
should be seeing this video it may or
may not be live there is a maintenance
going on to then add the new update into
the game so just keep that in mind if it
is not up yet and there's still a
maintenance don't worry just wait a
little bit it should take roughly an
hour to an hour and a half so don't you
worry it should be up there eventually
there showed a few bit of things today
they also showed the February roadmap
there's going to be the anniversary of
for honor who knows what we're gonna be
getting who knows what kind of
interesting stuff will happen that day
but regardless if nothing happens that
day it is the anniversary of the game
there's gonna be an extra lieu fest and
of course the launch today with some of
the content a couple times throughout
the month so a little bit of more
content of the week possibly going to be
to what we're relating to in the next
section of this video
but before that the hero Trials is alive
again last week I believe was the Wulin
and now this week it is every character
in the game all heroes are free for the
weekend I believe for the week or the
weekend I am a bit wrong you'll see the
time and stuff down below in the video
but once the trials are over you do have
to buy the characters again but you keep
all the progression and this is a way to
earn that progression and also be able
to play some new characters without
having just going to training but for
that content of the week today we have
the reluctant applause which is the new
content of the week from the emote
Contest Winner we've been talking about
this stuff for months they've finally
decided to come out with the emotes
obviously it takes time to do animations
and they do look a little bit different
based on the character so I'm definitely
intrigued to see how these characters
are gonna play with their kind of style
so you're just seeing an example of what
they gave us they just showed the very
four you know generic vanguards of each
of the factions which is still pretty
cool
you got some different stuff like
characters using their weapon and while
they're clapping some of them are
sheathing it stuff like that a lot of
different variation with these no clue
on what the prices but I'm going to
assume probably five to seven thousand
steal and then they just did a little
bit of a Q&A and then kind of showed a
trailer which we'll get into but for
that part the one thing they forgot to
mention is that if you do buy the
premium pass of the battle peso if you
get that premium paid version you
actually get a 10% gain of xp for the
battle pests you're gonna be getting a
lot more XP than someone who just has
the free version so definitely keep that
in mind if you want to get a little bit
of XP more but on top of that they also
showed this trailer and it was for the
year 4 trailer just kind of showing off
what we're gonna be getting kind of a
quick recap pretty much and they
actually had some new emotes in there I
saw a lute i saw a giant horn so we're
gonna be getting some musical instrument
emotes
I did mention I did see a few people
kind of you know shocked that it looked
like there was team emotes in the
trailer those are just the
rock-paper-scissor emotes and if you're
close enough together in game it can
kind of look like you're playing rock
paper scissors I wouldn't count that as
a team emote maybe that is a little
teaser to it but in my eyes I think
that's just showing off the
rock-paper-scissors demo and nothing
like crazy like I said they had a Q&A as
well and one thing is that warlord
actually got the wrong armor a couple of
you people actually in the comments
mentioned this to me
warlord actually got the wrong armor so
if you are a warlord main or you play
warlord and you saw my past video where
they showed off the armor that was
actually incorrect they showed the wrong
armor so for warlord players if he
didn't like the armor there is still
hope that there's going to be some
juicy-looking stuff for him the battle
past will only be available with money
and not steal you can of course use
steam wallet if you are a PC player but
it has to be paid I believe it is $10
u.s. it's obviously different per
currency but you cannot use in-game
currency aka steel to buy this heroes
will not be available in the past so you
never have to worry about that and once
the season is over the content
disappears if you don't get the content
you know you never get it again but if
you do achieve it then you get to keep
it forever which is really cool and
lastly I do want to talk about the year
for season one battle pass so that
actually like I said in the trailer they
showed a very very quick video of what
was actually in all of the tiers and
that was really exciting to see sadly
though of course 90% of the stuff just
has icons of characters that look like
effects and stuff so we won't be able to
see what those effects are which is why
I'm not going to go too in depth on this
vid
oh just yet I'm gonna go very in-depth
when the game actually launches and the
you know the years out so that we can
see the effects and the stuff in action
but it's just a quick brief we're gonna
be getting a lot of different armor it
seems like steel is gonna be definitely
thrown there in the mix it seems like
the weapons are evenly spread out a lot
of the main kind of like Vanguard ish
characters seem to be getting their
stuff a lot with shaman getting her
somewhere in the 80 so there's a lot of
different weapons coming out I see
gladiators at 71 a lot of different
stuff here I mean there's colors there's
weapons there's scavenger crates as a
bunch of stuff but then we get to tier
100 and I'm not exactly sure what the
whole theme with this little baby dragon
is which is I think like one of the
first effects you get it like tier 5 or
something but at tier 100 it seems like
there's going to be an outline that's
going to release on top of also the
woodlands seemingly getting an execution
although I could be wrong that to me
looks like the icon for an execution and
at 97 all the Knights kid at 98 all the
samurai in 99 is the Vikings and at 100
all the Wulin get it and then you get
the outline for completing the whole
past personally to me I'm not a big fan
of the outline just already looking at
the this brief little picture here but
if those are executions and I am correct
I am totally down to see what those are
I cannot wait to see those and I will
definitely give you guys a video as soon
as the year goes live so we can actually
see what these look like and not some
other stupid [ __ ] and just showing you
this picture but yeah that's gonna be
really the majority of the video I do
want to mention that I will be live on
Twitch right now as soon as the year
goes live we're gonna be talking about
you know all this stuff as soon as the
battle past video goes live we're gonna
be live on Twitch we're gonna be showing
off the new year look at all the new
juicy stuff grinding the battle past
having a load of fun so if you guys want
to stop by my link for meit's which will
be down in the description hopefully do
stop by they'll be greatly appreciated
guys take care have a great today I'll
see you probably in an hour or so with
the battle past video peace out let me
know how you enjoy here for
[Music]